Plus this China make it to the moon.
They grew cotton on the moon
apparently already. Right.
They grew something in the moon
but it died. Yeah, it died quickly.
I was happy that it was that
cotton because seeing as
how they're their biggest
investor in Africa and China was growing
cotton that didn't go well for black
people 500 years ago.
So I was just like,
please don't let cotton grown in the moon.
I don't know what the trends move.
Atlantic slave trade, the start and
I have to learn mandarin and shit.
So you do you think they actually set
up shot before us or as American steel
number one because they feels like, I
feel like we lost that day. We went,
China landed on the moon. Yeah. I feel
like I feel like, oh shit. You know,
you know I've grown up being, you know
like I'm black, I'm American, but I like,
I come here, a lot of people I'm saying
I live from here. I like America. Yeah,
exactly. I feel like we are
bad. Like Frederick Douglass.
When asked would he leave? Was
I, and I answered, you know,
like what the fuck am I going to leave
for when I see something like the moon
landing the China, the growing the plants
and landing there, there what, what,
what exactly was it? Was it, uh, what,
what was the kind of ship
that they landed on the moon?
I'm going to put one on the morning.
Apparently some type of role on the dark
side though right on the side that we
didn't make it to her or just went
and told him he got a video of,
it was a drone, right? He said what? It
was some sort of a drone. I think of that.
I honestly think about that as a
win for science and for innovation.
I don't think about it in terms of like
nations cause I feel like that is done
by scientists.
That's done by the wizards and the,
so are you saying we're going to steal
the scientists because when Kennedy gave
the fucking speech,
Kennedy made it seem like the moon landing
was going to make us the preeminent
nation. And I think that's the
propaganda China's going to run it.
You don't think,
well,
I think they have some fucking amazing
technology and to deny that would be
ridiculous. But I also think that
it's important that everybody,
everybody be competitive in this.
Like if they,
if you really want to make things better,
you're not gonna,
you're not going to do that in a vacuum.
Gotcha.
What helps the technological innovation
and one of the reasons why it's so
accelerated is there's so
many people working on it.
It's not just a few people trying
to make cell phones better.
I got fucking so many geniuses out there,
so when I see something like this,
like they landed on the moon, I go, did
geniuses one you just gave me hope. Yeah.
Yeah. They're Chinese people, but they're
just people. We're all just people.
Absolutely.
You know,
and the idea that they're going to all
get those people on that side to think
the same way is what we're
worried about. Right. That we're,
it'd be US versus them and
their technology is going
to impact our lives the way
we frame it as the country.
Yeah. We always worry about that,
but you have to admit that that's what,
that's the way we frame it.
But if you look at the history
of the world that's been,
that happens so many times.
I think it makes sense to be worried
about the rest of the world. I get it,
I'm on it and I'm on this side of
the fence, so no problem with that.
But you know,
you know I'm an American,
so you definitely want to know if it's,
if red October is going to
happen tomorrow, fuck man,
I think Russians don't hate us.
I don't think anybody has a
quarrel with anybody over there.
It's the the government's.
It's what's the hustle is that the real
interaction is between a very small
amount of people that involves all,
these are the people that are with them.
For some strange reason,
I think they should just be thrown
essentially in a stadium to fight to their
death would be the king of
the word. Fuck everybody up.
And that other dude that runs the other
little country next door that was on
real sports. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That guy is a huge supporter of MMA.
Fucking bad ass.
There's some bees over there.
You know bad Putin would fuck up Trump.
Oh Christ.
You can't fight to the death with Putin.
I where I would actually probably bit
poon versus Obama too. Yeah, for sure.
Look, Obama is probably better than it.
Debate. Yeah. Pools a real, exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
It's a real cat.
You'd have to go all the way.
Bush one I think was bad ass. Maybe as a
younger man, I need you to leave the CIA.
You gotta have some killer in.
Yes. You know, he was a tough guy,
but I probably have to get all the way
back to Kennedy in terms of physical
prowess, and his back was bad. I think
you've got to go to Abraham Lincoln.
Lincoln. Yeah, he was wiring. He wasn't
that farmer bill farmer strength. He did.